we're very excited about our next guest
journalist writer and podcast host
malcolm gladwell he is the author of six
new york times bestsellers including
outliers the tipping point and david and
goliath and now gladwell is launching
the seventh season of his podcast series
revisionist history the show explores
events and ideas from the past that have
been overlooked or misunderstood it has
been downloaded more than
162
million times since 2019. 162 million
times malcolm gladwell joins us now
first on cbs mornings welcome yes yes
yes
good to see you again so let's talk
about this new season it's all about
experiments um and you came up with an
idea after finding a box from world war
ii what did that box reveal to you it's
this crazy experiment that's sort of
been overlooked during the second world
war there was a researcher
in minnesota who was really curious to
find out what's the best way to nurse
someone back to health after they've
been malnourished because obviously
junior all kinds of people were
were suffering from from starvation so
he convinced 36 men to come to minnesota
he put them underneath the football
stadium at the university of minnesota
and for six months he starved them
and he observed what they went through
and then he um brought them back to
health for over the over three months
after that and the men left these
testimonies on they they
18 of them these taped interviews and
they were sitting in the library of
congress no one listened to them i don't
think ever
and we discovered and they were the
basis for this we have a three-part
series about what these guys went
through over the course of that six
months physically and mentally
physically mentally psychologically
emotionally how it changed their lives
how they
uh how they viewed it they were all
conscientious objectors and this was
their service during the war it's an
incredibly moving story talking about
moving stories because malcolm you talk
to your family you talk to your mom you
talk to your brother i love your tagline
of your podcast focusing on the
overlooked and the misunderstood so i
thought what's overlooked and
misunderstood about his family but the
thing is the the point you're making is
the habits of kindness are contagious
really applies to your family and that
if we're ever on a desert island and we
have a choice between malcolm or his
brother jeffrey pick jeffrey
i do a little thing about my brother yes
another episode where i talk about my
family back in the 70s sponsored three
vietnamese refugees well along with a
group of their friends and i tell that
story and sort of dig into it and why
they did it and what it meant
mostly was i've been trying for seven
seasons to get my mom on my podcast and
i finally succeeded was it weird
interviewing her talking to her no she
my mom is uh my mom is one of those very
self-possessed west indian ladies who
has this beautiful low voice i just
thought this one she's made she's
amazing she's made for this this is like
you talk about how your family took in
the refugees and that that's
that was sort of core to who you guys
were yeah
are canada's very unique the story is
really about why is canada why does
canada take in so many more refugees
than any other country in the world and
why doesn't why don't why doesn't the
rest of the world follow canada's lead
as a canadian i'm you know i'm i'm
always happy to bang the drum for my
my my home country now malcolm um first
let me say i don't appreciate you
stealing the shine of best hair of the
day
i'm supposed to have that title on a
daily basis well there's what what do
you look great it's just the three of us
who are incompetent
sorry vlad
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's not funny to you but it's funny um
no i want to talk about the first
episode which is the magic wand
experiment um what is that exactly so
this was i had this idea that every
scientist in the world must have in the
back of their head the experiment they
would love to do but never could okay
right so so i called them up and i said
all right i would imagine if i gave you
a magic wand and you could wave away all
financial logistical ethical
constraints do the do the experiment
tell me that what that magical
experiment would be and it turns out
every single person i talked to said oh
of course i have one and they told me i
got i collected them all and some of
them were wild my favorite one was
uh well i won't say that my favorite one
that's too complicated
not right for television but one of them
is it's babies without penises
i'm not gay you said it not me but i
heard it
but you also said with all your humility
you said and i have the best magic wand
that's usually the next i have two
episodes on this and the second one is
where i give my magic wand what is it
well it only i'm going to say this
it involves salt
and we and it involves the city of akron
ohio yeah akron figure is huge in this i
don't know anyone's from africa that's a
good
you team have one about uh will and
grace that you said yes most important
[ __ ]
yes in his history this is history says
malcolm gladwell i said i haven't in 30
seconds or less why i have an entire
it's all about
will and grace was the last sitcom that
had a
meaningful effect on the way americans
thought about a consequential issue it
changed american minds about gay
marriage
there is
it is impossible for a television show
to do that today and i explain why yeah
um the we we all will and grace are
great this is gay pride puns right yes
will and grace an enormous vote of
thanks and i i had a hilarious interview
with the two guys who started that show
it's fantastic your podcast is so good
now it is
wonderful you make things that aren't
necessarily interesting no offense very
interesting yes it's the way you tell
the story it's your voice it's it's so
good everything everybody guess you can
say you're an outlier
[Laughter]
always great to have you malcolm
gladwell thank you very much